so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about totally awesome Hulk
and what I'm hoping is that at the end
of this video you'll have a better
understanding of how he fits into the
all-new all-different marvel landscape
as well as why Amadeus Cho was selected
to pick up the mantle from where Bruce
Banner left off
so amadeus cho first appeared an amazing
fantasy volume 2 issue number 15 in 2006
and was created by writer greg pak
alongside artist takeshi Miyazawa but as
we get into this I want to jump back for
a second and have a discussion about
both Greg Pak and the amazing fantasy
line of stories since both of these will
be instrumental in evolving Cho into the
newest version of the Hulk originally
existing as a leftover relic of the
science fiction era of comics and
functioning as an anthology series
focusing on short five to six page
stories dealing with monsters and beasts
the original amazing adult fantasy line
of stories saw contributions from artist
Jack Kirby Steve Ditko and Don heck all
of whom provided their own bits of
influence and carving out the respective
niches within the comic industry while
the first fourteen issues would retain
the amazing adult fantasy name with
issue number 15 the title was rebranded
to amazing fantasy and saw the
introduction of Spider Man going on to
achieve his own solo series seven months
later due to his popularity because of
Fantastic Four had been introduced in
November of 1961
and it paved the way for Marvel to
transition to stories based on
superheroes with issue number 15 the
amazing fantasy line was closed down
allowing Marvel to begin focusing almost
exclusively on superhero theme stories
now where Marvel premiere and Marvel
preview would be launched in 1972 and
1975 respectively as anthology series
almost identical to amazing fantasy but
focusing on more realistic heroes and
introduced characters like star-lord and
Rocket Raccoon well I don't have a
concrete reason for this after having a
conversation with salic Kelley pop the
general consensus between the two of us
was that with editor-in-chief Joe
Quesada looking to return Marvel to what
he considered to be its former glory
by reducing the number of mutants
retconning Peters mayor's to Mirajane
and disbanding the Avengers the amazing
fantasy series was brought back as a
nostalgia trip of sorts
using the first fourteen issues to
introduce heroes like a Rania korazin
who would go on to undertake the mantle
of Spider Girl as well as a female
version of scorpion and vampire by night
because the original amazing fantasy was
an anthology series issue number 15 of
the second
vol look to introduce newer characters
who would go on to become as popular as
spider-man while some of these
characters included the great video by
Daniel way
blackjack by Dan Slott and monstro by
Robert Kirkman the introduction of
Amadeus Cho came under the guise of a
character named mastermind accel o by
Greg Pak in his first appearance the 7
page story of Amadeus Cho didn't
actually reveal much about his personal
life instead because issue number 15 was
more of a preview of the character with
his further expansions based on his
popularity all packed really established
here was that an unknown enemy had blown
up the house of Amadeus Cho and his
family killing his parents in the
process and that he was being pursued by
both the unknown group as well as
authorities both of whom had looked to
capture him for their own ends in
addition to this pact established that
Amadeus Cho had been declared the
seventh smartest person on the planet
and where this was initially left
ambiguous the discovery of this fact was
expanded on with the reveal of Amadeus
how he won a contest called the
mastermind accel Oh which had been
hosted by the excel of Soap Company now
again because this story was more of a
preview Pak leaves a lot of information
unanswered here but the intriguing
element of his character came and that
while eating at a diner and unaware that
the restaurant also contained Bruce
Banner with a local television news
station broadcasting a story of Chow
following the bombing of his house Cho
uses a portable scrambling device to
block the television signal something
that banner had noticed but chose not to
speak on however when the waitress came
to Cho it take his order but discovered
that he had rescued a baby coyote after
his mother had been run over she drew
the attention of one of the local police
officers who attended a forced show to
hand the puppy over and response to a
previous rabies pandemic now at this
moment Pat gave us a glimpse into what
show is capable of by the way in which
it was displayed lifts many of the
story's readers confused as to what
exactly was going on on his face the
indication was that show had some kind
of ability relating to magic or
mind-control but in truth Cho possesses
a mind that allows him to calculate an
almost unlimited number of possibilities
in any given situation with regards to
this scenario and the time it took for
him to reactivate the television and
turn the volume all the way up he had
figured out that his best method of
escape was to shoot the cop with a lemon
seed splash both the Cobb and the
waitress with pepper and kick over the
pie shelf leaving them half blind and
covered in food
continuing to demonstrate the abilities
of
with the unknown enemies continuing to
pursue him as well as the officer the
waitress in banner following him outside
when one of the enemy's helicopters
approached after monitoring one of the
police frequencies after firing a
missile aimed at show in an effort to
kill him
Amadeus uses the rear window mirror to
deflect the laser tracking sending the
missile off towards banner who
transforms into the Hulk and survives
the encounter now this bit of the story
is extremely important to the future of
Amadeus Cho and that both he and banner
will become extremely intertwined not in
the sense of being friends but in the
sense that showing himself will view
banner as more of a friend the encounter
between the two is short-lived and that
hope makes the case that both himself
and Cho are inherently stronger in both
character and conviction leading to him
taking off and leading Cho behind now
for Greg Pak his creation of Amadeus Cho
was not accidental during a conversation
I've had with Greg Pak at 2015's Los
Angeles kamikaze con he had stated that
the creation of Cho actually came out of
his personal desire for more
korean-american representation at comics
historically while Black Panther is
stormed Sam Wilson Luke Cage and Adam
Brashear had provided a level of
relatability for black readers and
Jubilee Sun fire horn and others had
created a level of relatability for
Japanese and Chinese readers the packet
found that the industry actually seemed
to be ruthless and in terms of
representation well I wouldn't go as far
as to say this demographic was being
outright ignored by Marvel I will say
that the indication from Pak was that as
both someone who had been reading comics
all his life as well as a writer who
himself was korean-american the concept
of using amazing fantasy as a chance to
introduce a new hero of korean-american
descent was extremely alluring however
the issue that packet faced was that
with amadeus cho having no powers and no
real connection to the mainstream Marvel
Universe his work was cut out for him
and that he had to find a way to make
show intrigue but also bring in
prospective readers who were
apprehensive about buying into the hype
to this end and as part of the Planet
Hulk event Amadeus Cho began to make
limited and sporadic appearances in the
main Marvel continuity as a wafer pack
to slowly introduce his character to
readers and test the waters with various
expansions with Planet Hulk Cho's
character was only brought in by name
and referenced by Hulk who he referred
to as a friend
following this and going into the Civil
War battle damage report
Greg Pak established that the
intelligence of show made him one of the
top 10 smartest people on the planet now
this is extremely important for the
development of CHO and the reason why
was because this separated him for the
rest of Marvel's lineup but also made
him the same what I mean here is that
these smartest characters of Marvel
Comics come in the form of Reed Richards
his daughter valaria and Doctor Doom
while switching between the number one
spot followed by any combination of
Black Panther Adam Brashear Tony Stark
beast hate him and spider-man but all
these heroes share the common trait of
having some kind of power where Tony
Stark is the most human of them all and
that his power stems from the knowledge
that he put to use and developing the
Iron Man armors the Greg Pak throwing
Amadeus Cho into this list of characters
without powers made him somewhat of a
free radical as a result even if
interest didn't exist among most
immortals fanbase at the time enough
interest existed that some eyebrows are
being raised at the idea of what could
be done with a character of Cho using
this to his advantage the most
significant role of Amadeus Cho and
Marvel Comics prior to the launch of
totally awesome Hulk
came with the Incredible Hercules
written by Greg Pak and drawn by Fred
Van lint the idea for the Incredible
Hercules came out of Greg Pak intending
to launch a follow-up series to world
war hulk titled the renegades which
focused on the various characters who is
sided with banner during the world war
hulk event and how their lives had
unfolded in their attempts to escape
shield
however for editors mark penny Chia and
Nate Crosby the idea of team books was
packed and that the Fantastic Four the
Avengers New Avengers and the various
x-men H force at x-factor related titles
were still being published looking to
deviate away from the large team book
and focus on smaller numbers Greg Pak
was paired with Fred Van lint for the
idea of creating a more lighthearted Odd
Couple series by bring abba Deus Cho and
Hercules together taking place over six
story arcs the pairing of Amadeus Cho
and Hercules took Marvel by storm and
that were Hercules was brave strong and
powerful Amadeus was the brains of the
operation
as a result the snarkiness between the
two coupled with their attempts to stay
under shields radar and avoid the
capture of Ares the Greek god of war
created a natural source of comedy and
action which in turn gave readers a
reprieve for the darker stories largely
found in the post-civil war era
leading into the events of Dark Reign
and siege now where the incredible
Hercules ended after around 30 issues
with Hulk returning to the title the
character of Amadeus largely returned
back to the realm of obscurity making
background appearances and Marvel as
part of fear itself and Savage Land
while this did serve to help keep him
fresh in the minds of fans who knew of
his character the issue faced by new
fans who were jumping into marvel during
the events of time runs out and
preparation for the launch of Secret
Wars was as they did not know why it was
that Amadeus was being featured in these
stories looking to solve this problem by
setting the stage for Cho becoming the
Incredible Hulk when The Secret Wars
event officially launched Greg Peck
organized a prelude to the Planet Hulk
secret worst hi in which provided a
backstory explaining how it was that
reality saw the earth filled with
different versions of The Incredible
Hulk picking up in Phoenix Arizona
amidst an alternate reality unlike the
main model timeline at some point
society on this realities earth had
experienced an unprecedented era of
technological advancement due to banner
having never become the Hulk and the
world's top minds using their knowledge
to advance society itself where Amadeus
largely remained the same as his main
Marvel counterpart and that he was
headstrong highly intelligent and a
little arrogant the concept of gamma
radiations the existence came when he
began using it to genetically engineer
pigs for the purpose of beefing of their
size and making better bacon now before
the lecture of banner was able to
continue any further shield director
Nick Fury ahead of foreign Bruce that
this reality's version of advanced idea
mechanics a terrorist organization
looking to conquer the world through
technological means had launched a
series of nuclear attacks against the
Earth's major cities with the intention
of sparking complete and total nuclear
war is seeking to keep this from
happening
Amadeus and several other members of
banner industries had taken to
intercepting the missiles with the hopes
of disarming them before their arrival
however because the Rockets were
traveling at Mach 19 which equates to
around 15,000 miles per hour the time
necessary to disable the missiles was
unavailable looking instead to keep the
population alive
Amadeus had feared the rockets into the
banner industries tower setting off an
explosion that killed Amadeus in the
process but spread gamma radiation
throughout the world transforming the
entire planets inhabitants into Hulk's
now regarding the totally awesome Hulk
comic book aligned and a September 2015
interview with comic vine calm prior to
the series launch writer Greg Pak had
stated that when model was fleshing out
the decision to launch Secret Wars
because the event was designed to
provide a fresh start for fans who were
looking to get into the Marvel Universe
the idea was to remove Bruce Banner as a
title character and pass the mantle on
to someone new keeping the name secret
in the months leading up to the titles
launch during this time editor mark
Bonita had reaffirmed the idea of
Amadeus Cho taking over the title role
due to his intertwining history with
Bruce Banner the issue here however is
that because the start of the Marvel
prime universe picks up eight months
after the end of Secret Wars with no
indication of what had happened during
this time the story of totally awesome
Hulk did not originally offer any
information on how Amadeus Cho became
the Hulk or what had happened to Bruce
Banner that said the reason why I waited
so long to produce this video was it
with issue number four released in March
of 2016 this issue finally provided a
backstory to the events leading up to
the start of totally awesome Hulk what
Pak tells us is that four months prior
to the start of issue number one Bruce
Banner had responded to requests for aid
from Ironman and black panther and
stopping a nuclear meltdown on kyra
island off the coast of Kenya because of
the fact that neither stock nor T'Challa
could halt the meltdown using their
knowledge banner had transformed into
the Hulk after which he absorbed the
entirety of the nuclear radiation into
himself the result was that with the
Chiron nuclear plant producing a
prototype form of radiation completely
separate from the gamma radiation of the
Hulk Bruce Banner was quite literally
turned into a walking nuclear reactor on
the verge of exploding and releasing a
massive surge of radiation that could
have potentially wrecked the world now
the reason why Greg Pak is taking this
line of thinking is that as we know the
Hulk persona is constantly angry and
thrives on that anger to boost his power
the problem is that as long as the hope
remains angry the kyra and gamma
radiation continue to swirl and
fluctuate inside of him teetering even
closer to detonation
as a result and because amadeus cho had
been such a close friend and fan of the
hulk the belief of Iron Man in Black
Panther was that Amadeus would be able
to calm Banner down long enough to allow
his body to proper
absorb the khyber radiation and disperse
it or else merge with it and form a new
kind of hope
to this end with Joe arriving on the
scene and learning of the situation
instead of a timid to communicate with
Bruce he made the decision to spare him
of his lifelong struggle and simply
absorb the power of the hope now again
the reason why PAC took this road was
that the whole persona within banner is
a reflection of his anger and rage at
the world and depending on what stories
you read his past experiences with his
abusive father for amadeus cho however
he has no internal struggle of this kind
instead when he absorbed the energy of
the Hulk his mind didn't fracture into a
split personality and instead Hulka dama
Deus became one of the same now with the
rest of totally awesome Hulk would
really just focus on Amadeus acting the
way we all would with power of this
magnitude and that he hits on women
teams up with Miles Morales and makes
jokes about she-hulk being 40 years old
Greg Pak did not actually provide a
conclusion as to what happened to Bruce
Banner instead the back story concluded
with banner apologizing to Amadeus for
the decision he'd made and the life he
was forced to lead and that over the
course of the next several issues The
Incredible Hulk persona that we were
used to seeing in the pre secret war
stories began to crop up as a reflection
in a mirror or simply standing in the
background of Amadeus Cho subconscious
mind now where Greg Pak will go with
this line of thinking is a question I do
not have the answer to but I would
surmise that with Amadeus having
absorbed the power of the Hulk the
darker persona present in Bruce simply
rests in the mind of Amadeus Wally uses
the Hulk powers and Bruce Banner himself
now actually lives as a normal human
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end I know this video
is a little finicky but so is Amadeus
Cho it was really kind of out of thin
air it was really out of left field that
he was chosen to be the Incredible Hulk
which again so kind of boggles me a
little bit but the story itself is
pretty interesting and for those of you
who have read the totally awesome Hulk
line so far post a comment below and let
me know what you guys think
now we'll catch you all later
you